you probably can't expect the second let
it go but chances are pretty high that
there will be some songs with the high
recognition value in the second part of
frozen as well singer and Deena Menzel
is very proud of the music she
contributed to the second part and
promises and outstanding storytelling as
well as story technical developments
which were skillfully packed into songs
similar to the first part a small
preview of the song selection of the new
Disney film was already given recently
at the d23 Expo where Menzel who is also
the dubbing voice of Elsa gave her
unmistakable voice to the best the other
dubbing actress also seem enthusiastic
including Jonathan Groff the voice of
Christopher who has to admit that he had
goose bumps all over his body during
Menzel performance on the d23 so you can
be curious what the firm will bring with
it it has a gigantic fan base anyway
since the successful first part frozen 2
will be released in the US on 22nd of
November 2019 the Joker movie isn't even
out yet and it already breaks some
records at the preview in Venice the
film received eight minutes of
continuous applause and afterwards only
overwhelming reviews this is also
evident in the movie database IMDB
rather Joker has just received a rating
of nine point six for comparison
Avengers end game only had an eight
point six rating on IMDB shortly before
its release on different social media
platforms people of course also talked
about the film and even they talked
about an Oscar ready performance by jock
in Phoenix so the hype so far is quite
big which means that the benchmark for
all future viewers will be just as high
who can find out well of the film will
live up to your expectations from 2nd of
October 2009 t as the Joker will then
also be released in u.s. cinemas the new
Batman Robert Pattinson has met his
first comprehensive statement about his
new role and this for the first time
since the announcement of his role not
all these events like the choice of
actors very much which is quite
understandable especially in the movie
world new things are always seen with
thumb suspicions in an interview with
Variety Pattinson talks about some
inside information so Pattinson himself
was the one who took the initiative to
become the new Batman
he had pushed director matterif so long
until the meeting finally took place the
problem for the press also heard about
this meeting and so rumors were
spreading at the Cannes Film Festival in
the meantime Pattinson actually thought
he was out because the public at the
whole of it but in the end he succeeded
against his competitor nicholas hoult
that was in June 2019 Pattinson
describes the audition in the Batsuit as
one of the craziest things as you
supposedly feel incredibly powerful
despite the fact that you need about
five people to get in at all
Pattinson also commented on the partly
strong disgrace about his person
according to his own statement he even
expected much more hatred he sees it
positively and takes advantage of it
because as an underdog you can only
exceed your expectations
by the way the shooting of the Batman
was started in winter this year the US
release will be on June 25th 2021 since
the conflict between Sony and Marvel
came to the public and caused huge waves
fans are wondering what spider-man actor
Tom Holland thinks about it yes he did
say a few words at the last d23 Expo but
now he even revealed more in an GQ
interview in that interview he says he
is sure that the future and legacy of
spider-man is in good hands with Sony
he's also more than grateful and has
made many friends in addition Holland
raves about the last five years at
Marvel at the same time he admits that
spider-man future will definitely be
different yet he's sure that it will be
just as exciting sounds more like
diplomatic phrase mongering than
concrete statements no wonders in Sony
and Disney might agree after all it
remains to be seen how Tom Holland has
spider-man at Sony will continue in the
future because there are no
announcements yet there's gonna be a
sequel to the tomb parade a movie
already at the beginning of the year and
inside a confirm that there will be a
sequel and that any jump will write the
script but now it's official the film
studio MGM also hired director Ben
Wheatley for the production also the
information about a medium turned out to
be true the main actress Alyssa Wieck
and I will also return in her role as
Lara Croft
however it's not yet known what the plot
will be about it might be possible to
orientate oneself on the last Tomb
Raider videogames but something
completely new
also imaginable by the way the movie
will be released in the USA on march
19th 2021 for weeks it seemed that
former One Direction singer Harry Styles
was going to play Prince Eric at
Disney's new erielle film then he turned
the studio down completely surprisingly
in mid-august the 13 reasons why actor
Christian Navarro applied to Disney for
the role of Prince Eric on Twitter and
it looks like Disney is now really
interested in the Barrow because on
September 3rd Navarro again wrote a
tweet in which he announces that Disney
SAW has altered due to the high
resonance and now wants to see his
abilities it remains exciting to see if
Navarro also gets the role at the end of
the day but at least this would be a
funny story that started with a harmless
tweet a release of the erielle remake
isn't yet certain but many expect the
cinema release before 2021
[Music]